september dane says i have to do it  again  my things weren't properly folded she  says who cares how they're folded  they're going to get all messed up  anyway  it's good you've got help watch  nymeria gloves  impressive shut up now myria  gloves  i have something for you and it has to  be packed  very carefully a present  close the door  this is no toy  be careful you don't cut yourself  you're so skinny so were you  i had the blacksmith make it for you  special i won't hack a man's head off  but it can poke him full of holes if  you're quick enough  i can be quick you'll have to work at it  every day  how does it feel do you like the balance  i think so first lesson  sticking with the pointy end i know it's  end to use  i'm going to miss you  careful  all the best swords have names you know  sansa can keep her sewing needles  i've got a needle of my own  you